like i'd love to have like a landline in
my room
i think that's you can get one they
still do them they make them you can get
one ask your parents
i will it's iconic
hello babysitters club hi i'm jenny
moore and i played claudia kishi on the
babysitter's club in the 90s
i'm ramona tamata and now 30 years later
i'm playing claudia yukishi on the
babysitter's club tv show and we
are about to interview each other for
e.t
my first question for you is what was it
like to represent a
japanese-american character in 1990.
look times were
different in 1990 um there wasn't much
representation
at all of asian american women and girls
or on tv or even hollywood it was really
limited
we were always kind of like sidekicks
and
oftentimes fit that really model
minority myth so like super quiet and
smart
overachievers bookworms definitely not
creative
and bold and confident main characters
like claudia
get beautiful get smart let me make you
into a work of art
well like joker yet almost even though
at the time i really didn't
understand how much it meant it was
really important to be a part of
changing that narrative so looking back
i understand so much more how meaningful
it was to so many girls out there um to
see an asian girl
being fun and artistic and just standing
out in such a
big way and being bigger than life like
claudia is
miss kishi stop defacing your shoes and
pay attention
you wouldn't want to have another failed
quiz on your average would we
i think she just breaks all these
stereotypes
and she's just so i think
unapologetically like herself
you're agreeing with me right absolutely
she just is confident in her own skin
and really doesn't care about what
anyone else thinks about her and i think
that like kind of was rare because it
didn't
fit like the asian stereotype that you
would see on screen
summer look that's a proof
even after the show came out i've gotten
like mail from fans have been like thank
you like this is
really the first time i've seen myself
being accurately represented on screen
and that like
that just means the entire world to you
to to be like
wow like i actually i'm able to inspire
young girls
and they're able to you know maybe gain
confidence just by seeing
someone that like looks like them or
just has like similar personality traits
and i think
that's what's so great about just
claudia and bs in general that everyone
i feel like can identify as like a
different girl
if not multiple i am ready to celebrate
i have been dreaming of banana splits
and candy
all day long my next question for you is
what was the most memorable thing
about playing claudia so like that's
easy
i'm sure you've had the same answer
we're gonna see in a minute but it had
to be her wardrobe
and getting to eat junk food on set all
the time i think it's a great idea
so all the other actresses were super
jealous of claudia's wardrobe
just the fun loud colors and prints the
funky hats and of course
the earrings can't forget the earrings
they're so
cute i love them thank you guys oh yeah
what was your favorite thing about
playing claudia i mean i think i'm gonna
have a pretty similar answer to you
but definitely just like her wardrobe
and just being able to kind of
i think when you have all the different
like components like her wardrobe her
hair
and just everything it just it makes you
feel
i definitely got kind of like this
energy rush just from playing
claudia because she just has this fun
and like contagious personality that i
just love so much
and um definitely eating the candy for
sure
twizzlers watermelon gummies and cake
just it probably got so many cavities
but it's okay it's just such a fun
experience
did you read the bsc books like in your
childhood at all
of course um everyone i knew read the
books growing up
that was the era back then you gotta
remember this is a long time ago we
didn't have youtube we didn't have
netflix
we didn't even have social media social
media writes your brain
matter of fact on demand wasn't even a
thing so if you missed a tv show unless
you bought
like a vhs tape and pushed record you
missed it forever
so we read a lot um and yes i love the
babysitter's club i read
i can't say i read all the books i read
a lot of the books
definitely every claudia book and
honestly every
eight to 12 year old girl that i knew
did the same thing it was a
big deal you asked me i'm asking you
back did you read the babysitter's club
books
before you landed the role i did
actually in grade two i would say i
think
maybe a little later i just was obsessed
with the bsc in elementary school
so like during lunches my teacher had
like this like little library in her
classroom and we just like
read the books and i would say at like
lunch and stuff
we'd pretend to be a part of the bsc as
i think a lot of
like just kids did in general yeah um
and i
claudia was just such an inspiration to
me so just thinking that i get to
portray
her like years later is just insane um
but yes i did read the books and i loved
them
very much i can't live without the
babysitter's club
and the babysitter's club can't live
without me
you know i'd love to hear about kind of
your personal experience playing claudia
and how did that like
influence you growing up
um so that was my first
and only acting job um it was my second
audition i want to say but it was an
amazing first job so it's influenced me
in ways that i can't even describe
because it really shaped
a lot about me from a work ethic
standpoint you know allowed me to
um you know pay for some of my college
um when i graduated from high school and
that's an opportunity i might not have
had so
it's it's changed my life for sure in a
kind of a different conversation it's
really empowered me like i say now
looking back at it
um it's really empowered me in a big way
to kind of as
a reminder and an introduction um that
the world doesn't always see you the way
that you see yourself
right so whether it was playing claudia
and helping to break through some of
those stereotypes
30 years ago or being you know an active
mentor
an ally like i am now to the minority
communities
and cultures as an adult it matters by
just showing up and standing up when it
counts and it may not seem
like it's you know changing the world
but if it changes someone's experience
than it is
but when i was growing up a long long
long time ago characters like claudia
were
rare what kind of fantasy world do you
inhabit my world
why do you have to criticize everything
i do i don't criticize you for loving
mathematics
maybe we should just stay in our own
world and i found it to be inspiring to
me
do you think things have changed i know
you weren't around in the 90s
but do you think that that's still a
thing where
it's uncommon or more uncommon to see
asian women and girls
break out of that stereotype or do you
think it's still here i think
we're slowly starting to kind of break
that
but i can't confirm and say 100
that all the stereotypes for you know
asian americans in general have been
broken
i think there are still kind of you know
those few characters that
definitely still do follow that
stereotype a little bit and
i think like you mentioned just having
characters like
claudia she's really slowly but surely
just
changing kind of the world of film just
representation and diversity
but uh i think it's something that we're
slowly working towards and i have seen
just like a difference the past few
years
even with auditioning and stuff so yeah
there is some change but we're not there
yet we're not there yet well look you
know
you're playing a huge part of that so
just don't don't ever underestimate that
um that impact that you have because
you're a part of creating that change so
that's that's something you should be
really proud of
okay it's raining hold on i gotta earth
to
go
what sorry it was pouring down rain so i
had to run up under the cover so i
apologize for the break
um but i'm dry and i'm safe so it's okay
okay
what were my favorite pieces of iconic
like favorite iconic outfits from
claudia i can tell you
a hundred percent purple tights black
boots i know it's 30 years later i know
treble ties black boots a gray short
jumper over the tights a jean jacket
and earrings made out of noodles i
remember that outfit
so clearly i don't know why but i do
think of all the beautiful clowns um
i'm trying to think season one there's
there's a ton of good outfits in season
two too guys
and that's the only thing i'll say but
uh season one
she had this one outfit
it was like a denim overall kind of
jumpsuit thing
and it had like custom little patches on
it so it had like
um they painted like this face on it and
she wrote vsc on it
and it just looked like something that
just like claudia she just like drew all
over herself and like
there was a bunch of like different
fabrics within the one
i still have that actually it was just i
kind of have it just as like a keepsake
but
that was like my favorite outfit ever oh
that sculpture is cool what's it about
menstruation so i actually have had the
opportunity to watch
the new series mo i love it you're
amazing
it is so fun for me to watch it i'm a
parent now
i've got kids older than you um so to
see
you know how you've recreated and
brought back claudia
in such a unique way that so you i just
um it makes me feel so proud to have
been a part of version one
and just amazed and astounded to see
what you guys are doing with version two
your work is
absolutely beautiful thank you i watched
um
clips from the original show and i think
it's just so interesting because there's
something about claudia that i think
is just kind of carried on like just by
each generation
it's just so cool to see other people be
kind of like portraying the same
character because everyone has
i think something different to bring to
the character from like their own
personalities
it's just crazy to think that
i'm inspiring others and i think
um one thing i've kind of learned from
the experience
is just to really uh use my platform to
you know educate others and also to just
um hopefully continue to
inspire others to make change and you
know who knows maybe
if they do another reboot of vfc they
might be playing the next claudia which
is
just crazy for me to think but i mean it
it definitely happened a few times so it
could be a
possibility you know oh my god
hello babysitters club what did i think
about them putting the landline
in the new series well i mean i will say
before even the show i didn't know what
a landline was but i'd never used like a
real one before
so just seeing the like iconic landline
and it's so cool it's like clear and it
has all these like
lights and colors that was just like we
were
so so so excited just seeing it for the
first time
and i think it's so great that they
incorporated that because like like i
mentioned
bsc is so like timeless and i think
just incorporating kind of those little
things from the original book series and
like the original show i think
that's kind of just like a great kind of
like mark of
just how far babysitter's club has like
come
um just throughout like all these
different generations
hello babysitters club hello
babysitter's club i actually um
said to my husband that i was curious to
know if they were going to modernize
before we watched right like if they
were going to incorporate anything new
in with social media or
with you know even just technology like
will they be texting their clients
instead of calling them or taking phone
calls so
i was actually really happy to see it um
to be honest and kind of see that
consistency
um also because kids nowadays don't know
what landlines are so
you know it's educational as well um but
i really was kind of happy to see it i
was surprised and i was i was wondering
that if it was going to be
you know again basically club 3.0 where
you have texting and everything else
kind of in play or if they were going to
keep it traditional so happy to see it
it's iconic
oh my gosh good afternoon
babysitter's club like i'd love to have
like a landline
in my room i think that's you can get
one they still do them they make them
you can get one ask your parent
i will okay
so jenny what do you think claudia kishi
represents today versus in the 90s i
think in the 90s
because there was such little um
representation she was literally one of
the first
you know kind of younger characters that
you saw that was
um asian american and
you know kind of having that that
cultural
um breakthrough so for me i think the
90s character
90s claudia was kind of like prototype
1.0 right um in a time when
it wasn't even really a thing so now
to see how far we've come and it's no
longer
i feel like it's no longer an exception
to see
a really strong asian character like
yourself
you know claudia now um so what you
bring i think is refinement to that
right so it's not just hey i'm here
and i'm i'm not a stereotype but it's
yeah i'm here and
there's so much diversity within asian
americans
and you know there's so much more
complexity there that i think
i think you kind of bring that a more
refined view
of um of that representation to the
screen
um i just want to add to that i would
also say i think
seeing claudia now i think it just shows
how
far i think maybe the character of
claudia has grown
and like you can see you know all the
things she's
impacted throughout just like having her
and just having different generations
kind of grow up with her and i think
that's so great to see and just
continue to see such a strong character
like
rise on top
[Music]
you